what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I go over this week's
treachery debauchery and who had the
audacity before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos but
most importantly like the video on your
way and I am so tired of you guys
watching and not even liking a like is
free so let's get this video to 3 000
likes um to start the shoot okay guys so
today
Adam Adam Adam
has the audacity to call me a misogynist
and you know him calling me a misogynist
has just left me like crying at night
wondering how on Earth have I let people
think that I'm a misogynist I I've just
been crying myself to sleep every single
night because of this [__] these
horrible untrue things that are said
about me Adam
check
got screwed by this guy Jason love now I
don't know this Jason love I've never
heard of this guy before the shoot but
Adam let the shoot happen they've now
posted it and made whatever amount of
money mind you they have a daughter and
they don't care they just say daughter
I'm gonna play with your mental health
we'll do whatever we want on camera so
we can make the most money me me me me
me me and my happiness is first screw my
daughter and
now Lena has also said that she enjoyed
the sex with the other guy more than her
husband
let's see what they had to say about
this I mean even if he did Lay It Down
better that just means that I personally
need to step my game up yeah so that I
can you know compete
I'm gonna be honest though it was tight
as [__] before it could have used a
little straightening
so now he wants to compete with a corn
star
okay okay let's just let's just like
think about this
now obviously this is like treachery
debauchery craziness but imagine
if that's like saying a pickup
basketball player
needs to compete with somebody in the
NBA you know what I mean it's like what
like that's like saying
and this is just based off of you know
what they've been going that's like
saying a guy that's like six foot
it needs to compete with a guy that's
six set like it's like what is he
supposed to
he's a corn star you know what I mean
I get I guess you could argue they're
both corn Stars my producer King is
saying Adam's a corn star too I guess
that's how they view it do you think
this may like it's almost disrespectful
that they got married I was thinking
about this why couldn't they just stay
out of the business of marriage like
marriage is supposed to be a Sacrament
and it sort of degrades the sacrament
but we have people that are doing corn
enter marriage it's like
I I almost think that we should be able
to tell people no like no you are not
allowed to
enter marriage because it's like
couldn't you just do the relationship
thing like why marriage
um but my biggest issue with this whole
thing is the fact that they have a
daughter
so now let's see what Jason love had to
say about this whole thing pull it up oh
I actually saw the video released
yesterday I saw it
um first of all
wow
um second of all who whose idea was it
to end
yeah okay so I guess I had been
stretched out in a while so man I was
doing all the stretching it's like my
starting to get numb and I was like I
was like yo we have to keep going it was
going so long that it was it was nothing
I could do it was like the numbness I
didn't I didn't notice and I'm like yo
it's about you know and then hey it
happened it happened so there was not
planned nope
but then she got freaky with it she
started eating it you know
you know doing the nasty got to the
moment you know how it is once you get
into the moment it's like you know it's
all
no hose bar let's go
do you think that you are better than
Adam did well obviously yes
but I'm pretty sure it probably felt
different with Adam for her because love
has involved emotions but as for the
physical aspect of getting [__]
obviously you
can you imagine growing up in a world
where another dude is talking about
screwing your mom better than your dad
can you guys like imagine imagine
you're growing up you're going to school
having a grand old time now I I spoke to
Adam about this I think when I was on a
show and he said well you just wait till
they're older to tell them so now
imagine you mean what age is old enough
to know this let's just say 13 14 like
teenage years so you're a 13 14 year old
girl you're like hi Mom and Dad
and they say look we've been doing corn
for a decade now let's say they've hit
all of this which I can you really hide
all of it I don't know but let's just
say you have
13 14 and then they say
um yes we did corn
um and you go to school and someone
shows you this video
of this other guy that you don't know
talking about screwing your mom
are we gonna say this is the best
environment for a kid to grow up in now
literally I was thinking about this this
girl has nobody to protect her nobody
because her parents won't even do it
imagine growing up in a world where your
parents don't even want to protect you
like I I think there's some comfort as a
woman like knowing that if someone does
anything it's like you have a brother or
a father or someone to look out for you
but now we have daughters growing up in
Worlds where their fathers are
conditioned and not allowed to protect
them whether it's because the state took
them from the father or because the
woman has exerted so much control in the
relationship that the father cannot
protect his child
so now this led me to another tweet that
I saw okay now Adam wanted to make it
very clear that this was not put on the
corn site but on Lena's Lana's whatever
her name is that it was on the their
mommy Vlog site so on Twitter this guy
named Dom posted this video on October
13 2022 Adam and his wife Lena uploaded
their daughter breastfeeding to their
corn Tick Tock plug talk people began
accusing them of using their daughter as
a pedophile dog whistle it is worth
noting that Lena filmed pregnancy corn
fetish scenes as well
your account needs milk
they do all that Counting
trying to get how long it takes should I
get any pictures it's just strength into
a Parker and nursing session I like
bottle caps yes I do
now what kind of people do you think
follow them do you think it's like stand
up people that are that are watching
these corn scenes do you think they
uploaded that thinking nobody is going
to sexualize my daughter like really
like this is the thing there's nobody to
protect the kid
there is nobody to protect the child in
this and that's the disgusting thing
about it it's like why
it why would you upload that and the the
worst part the worst part
I was thinking about this
the kids don't consent to this so the
kid is growing up in an environment
where they're being used
on social media to further their parents
career I was thinking about this even
with like Mommy Vlogs and all that [__]
it's like is it healthy for a kid to be
recorded from the time they're like five
years old two years old like imagine
this we all have done some embarrassing
[__] when we were kids right we have all
done things that I mean we would not
want the world to see but now we live in
a society where the parents are putting
their kids on the internet and this is
one thing I've really respected about a
lot of the conservatives is they really
keep their family offline because one
you don't know who you're exposing them
to and two the kids don't get to consent
to this they don't get to consent to
being online and now you're in a
situation where there's nobody to
protect the kid
So Adam 22 saw this tweet
and he thought they they totally
misrepresented me
I I cannot believe they misrepresented
me so he tweets
or he dm'd this guy Dom lures looser
whatever
um
you guys know me I can't do names I
can't names just not my thing if your
name isn't one syllable
it's over for me oh he said Adam just DM
me the video of him and his wife
breastfeeding their daughter was
uploaded to Lena the plug's personal
Tick Tock and not the plug talk Tick
Tock Adam your wife is a corn star what
kind of followers does she have if she
was a pastor they would be Saints so he
wanted them to know
that this was uploaded to a vlog channel
oh thank God the Vlog Channel like
wow you are now absolved help adam22 and
his wife are attacking me both you were
speaking where the video was posted and
not the video itself Adam and Lena I
don't want to go next this guy had your
ass upside down I'm good this is posted
to my mommy Vlog account so this
statement is false plug talk is a
completely separate page why would you
lie about this all right you know here I
I am I am the Orbiter of truth I'm here
to give you guys truth so now I I ask
you this video was posted on her Vlog
Tick Tock and not her corn tick tock
is that better
is is this situation absolved was that
wise
what is everyone like oh oh
you posted that to your Vlog Channel
therefore I think that was a great idea
no nobody's
but he's creeped out about the actual
video why would you do that that is so
[__] up I am so glad I grew up with
two parents that did not do this [__] in
a generation where this
was not a thing because
I cannot imagine growing up in a world
where these were my parents this dog
this poor kid has nobody to protect her
and now we're coming to find out
that in some of their videos they have a
picture of the fridge
why is there a dick drawn on the fridge
and this is the thing guys if you're if
your whole career is sex there is no but
there is no way you can just Shield your
kid from that until they're older
because that's what they said oh we'll
just Shield the kid till they're older
they'll be fine there's always been
adult stuff and kids stuff
um how can you Shield the kid when the
entire world it kind of reminds me of
The Truman Show have you seen The Truman
Show because it's like um The Truman
Show was a movie where like this guy
grew up in a dome and everyone was
watching him like it was like um a fake
world and it was recorded and
broadcasted on TV and he grew up with
the entire world watching him but he
didn't know and I feel like that's what
a lot of kids are growing up in where
like the entire world is watching them
like the entire world is watching this
kid you cannot just separate this stuff
who you are as a person transfers onto
your kids your habits become your kids
it's not like you could just separate
who you are from your children so if
you're getting involved in this stuff it
really is a slippery slope and the sad
part is I don't even care if these
people screw up their own life
my thing is they screw up the lives of
the child that is what's important
and why would you jeopardize your kids
and this is the problem it's this me me
my feelings are the most important
Society instead of the kids
flagrant has also weighed in on this so
let's see what flagrant has had to say
so should we discuss this whole Adam 22
thing I think we did right I think we
handled it well we didn't discuss it
yeah what do you guys think
I mean I don't know that's uh that's a
boundary for me yeah I'm not blown away
by it for him though like if like he
does porn with a girl you know what I
mean like he's a podcaster he's a BMX
dude he's got all these Brands but he
also is a porn star
and so porn stars often like will act in
scenes is the way they see it with other
people so I don't see it as like for him
that crazy
that's the mother
I mean it's crazy
don't come back over
there
kept the truth the one that went to the
Muslim part of the world
every porn star does it is it weird for
porn stars to do this to do what to like
yeah you're broken thank you y'all all
been destined Destiny done [__]
radicalized out of the 22. radicalized
mark doesn't Destiny let his girl do
that [__] I don't know bro that's crazy
they're swingers swingers that cut that
down crazy [__] too stop calling it uh
thing that kids playing yeah it's not
swingers it's you let people [__] your
girl Loki filming is better than not
filming it though because not filming it
you're just doing it
you feel me you got money off hey hey
changed my mind with that one I think
this is a funny point if you film it I
think it's better dude then you get paid
I don't know because more people don't
know about it filming is better than not
filming
why is why is it in our society money
goes first you know at least if you're
doing The Swinging [__]
you could Shield that from the kids you
can be like I don't know it's like all
these all these conservatives that are
it's like coming out that they have
these swinging parties and all of them
are like I don't know what they're
talking about we did No Such Thing these
allegations
false false now look it I'm not saying
that's the best way to go I'm not saying
you should open up your marriage to that
but that is your parents denying
something they did is absolutely better
than filming it for the world
making zero dollars and your kids never
finding out except Whispers across the
town
is better than
them finding out yes
um I I don't know why he's even arguing
that and now he's like oh well it's corn
stars is it weird for cornstarch yeah
yes it's weird that's why everyone's
freaking out usually when a woman
becomes a corn star they just cast her
out they're like we're done with this
chick she's a concubine forever but now
they're becoming wives it's like what
Society are we living in and that's hard
the bank account would I and I haven't I
haven't texted that about this Captain
here say what I know he's like I got too
much money for my my wife to get donkey
[__] by some dude yeah and does that
mean
so there look here this is what I
thought it was and I haven't spoken to
Adam about it I I don't even want to
text him about it just too [__] weird
but uh but uh my what I thought this was
is you kill a story with a story I
texted you guys this to the group I
think as well which is like the story
about no jumper was it's falling apart
you had all this people that were like
the uh you know the
they're not staff they're like Talent
they're like on-air Talent
all leave leaves a huge vacuum what's
happening with the identity like what's
happening with the brand is the brand
done is it over and then announces this
thing and then all the conversation is
about this and none of it is about oh my
God all the people that were on the
channel have left it have gone done
their other things and no jumpers done
now people are being critical of this
for sure but it feels as if the entire
internet is talking about this one so
yeah and if Adam is cool with that he
doesn't care about the criticism because
he's getting all the views all the
attention and he's pivoting more into
something that maybe is working for him
which is hey I like the porn [__] I
don't give a [__] or make way more money
on the porn [__] than we did the gang
[__] so now I'm completely done with the
gang [__] and I do the porn [__] and I
do the podcast and it's gonna make crazy
money it's I wonder if it's just we're
doing one and then we're quitting the
internet
like I I literally wonder if it seems
like he's teeing up the next [__] yeah I
don't think he's doing one of them
quickly yeah who knows but yeah if you
are comfortable here's the thing after
one
there's uh minimal returns in my
personal opinion diminishing returns
yeah diminishing returns it's like how
many times do you need like once we know
you're okay with someone banging your
wife I don't need to see a third person
bang your wife the big one is the first
one yeah you've either got to go bigger
in size which is like
maybe 24.
that'd be crazy or it's got to be some
kind of like wild collapse he said
something about him and another dude
doing it that is another angle you could
go but I think this is a perfect example
of killing a story with a story
yeah I wonder how many dudes he's gonna
let screw his wife should we take bets
we should take bets I bet you two hits
at least two more dudes maybe through at
least three
screw his wife I don't think it'll be a
one-time thing but let me know in the
comments guys maybe it will but you see
this is the issue with like opening up
marriages and having us like do only
fans while being married and all this
and now we have a story of a young man
whose girlfriend does only fans so let's
pull up the story so this guy named Dan
had posted a question for the internet
to give him advice on now me you know
I'm just gonna give some golly old
advice so my girlfriend started in only
fans two months ago and after one month
she only had one follower me she was
upset and I felt bad for her I decided
to create multiple accounts and
subscribe to her so she would be happier
and more encouraged to continue with her
journey recently over the past few weeks
she's been messaging one of my accounts
which uses a very handsome mail profile
picture and she's been hinting at
meeting up with him I don't know what to
do right now do I tell her the truth
about what I'm doing or continue
pretending to be this guy to avoid
upsetting her she mentions being willing
to fly out to meet this dude I think her
heart would be broken if I told her
wow
can you
so let me get this straight this man is
such a bit I'm sorry I gotta call this
guy a [__] he's such a [__] that he's
afraid to upset his girlfriend who's
trying to cheat on him
now the comment says he needs to
confront her and then deal with the
issue
Dan needs to come off the app and forget
the whole thing
thank you Dre morale that's the right
answer he needs a new girlfriend yes
if Dan thinks of himself as some sort of
superhero I have a feeling a super super
name superhero name would be simp pagman
able to drink a gallon of soy soy milk
in a single gulp turn 25 beta males into
an alpha males in a single greeting his
weakness is obviously testosterone
Dan needs to walk away and exit the
relationship yeah guys okay one this
shows a couple things number one women
will always have the audacity the
audacity you have a guy that's okay with
you doing only fans and you're trying to
leave him for a subscriber
do you think the top tier guys are
subscribers
really and it's like he's letting her do
the only fans thing and the crazy thing
is can you imagine taking off your
clothes for money and getting one
subscriber
owl
Von like you wouldn't go around like
nowadays women's elves need to be told
across the town like
do you remember that guy in New York
City that all the women came together to
find out he was taking on the hit them
on like the same date and like they all
made accounts like talking about how we
took them on the same date and screwed
them and like whatever
and they made this man to be like the
worst man ever and I was thinking about
this I'm like what happened to the days
where you took an l and just never
talked about it you were like wow
he's seeing the whole town wow this is
an l and you just shut up and you moved
on and you didn't go to the internet and
tell everybody your elves funny thing is
I bet you this chick if she found out
what the boyfriend was doing would be
upset at the boyfriend instead of
thinking you know what maybe I should
stop only fans because this isn't for me
and this is a owl
so the next story you know they always
said women can just do anything
as women we are just so respectable and
we can just do anything a man can do so
as you guys know I am a female athlete
and I did take professional
um Athletics really to quite high level
I went semi-prone England I had um for
volleyball and I had a pro contract
offered to me in the fall I could have
went to a couple countries the YouTube
thing took off I did YouTube right but I
really understand
why professional women's sports are
frustrated because we do work like guys
I spent 16 years of my life training
like literally every day I would go to
school until three o'clock and then I
would I played two sports so I would go
to volleyball practice and I would go to
basketball practice so every day I would
train for four hours roughly a day a lot
of times I would drive an hour each way
so I wouldn't get home till like 10
o'clock at night so imagine spending
like six seven hours a okay on top of
school
for 10 plus years
um from the time I was 12 years old we
would travel out of state right so I was
at like 12 years old I would have a
tournament in Indiana I would have a
tournament in Vegas like I'd been to all
these states for volleyball
now imagine you do this you work so
incredibly hard and you become the top
one two percent of your sport right and
you usually think when you become the
top like two percent one percent in
skill of any profession that you're
gonna get paid but for women's sports
it's just not it I will never whine
about it because the market dictates
what we're paid and the truth of the
matter is I don't watch women's sports
most people don't want to watch women's
sports there's a reason we are paid less
but I understand where they're coming
from with their frustration about the
pay but the truth of the matter is it
just is what it is but what frustrates
me is when women are in a sport that
gets paid women that make it to the top
of their level right and actually and
because in other sports there's a little
bit more opportunity than the sport I
was in volleyball so like there's a bit
more opportunity and like um I did court
volleyball beach volleyball there's a
bit more
um and fighting I've heard female
Fighters actually get paid an okay
amount so this female fighter won some
boxing UFC type stuff I don't really get
it pull the clip
[Applause]
[Music]
so women will be like respect us
why don't you take us seriously we can
do anything a man can do then when we do
it
we take off our clothes
we take off our clothes which you know
at least she did figure this out really
the only way and I've thought about this
the only way women can really make money
at sports is through two things one
social media so Vlogs about the teams
getting rich parents to train your kids
and unfortunately taking our clothes off
all of all of the women's sports would
be profitable tomorrow
if women started taking off their
clothes now I don't say this as I wish
this would happen but I'm just a realist
guys if women started taking off their
clothes
they would in fact make more money but
what baffles me is we will whine about
inequality wine that we are not paid the
same and then this is what we do when we
get to the foreground but Pearl this
doesn't happen in other Industries right
a woman can just do anything a man can
do a woman can just a woman is our women
are so respectable that we come into a
man's world and we just dominate we just
kill it
now there is a surgeon
that has been making headlines for just
being so smart and respectable and just
really making advancements in the field
really just the top of her game roll the
clip
there's a tick tock Doctor Who was more
concerned with filming her patients
during surgery than the safety and
well-being of her patients Dr Roxy is
Tick-Tock famous with over 825
000 followers on the app
her negligence along with her obsession
with Tick Tock has led to her medical
license being permanently revoked but
her lack of professionalism and for
judgment and delegate your
responsibilities to others
significantly contributed
for calling below the standards of Care
Dr Catherine Roxanne growy better known
as Dr Roxy being accused of injuring
patients while live streaming some
procedures on Tick Tock never again will
she be able to work as a doctor in Ohio
after the State Medical Board voted on
Wednesday July 12 2023 to permanently
revoke her medical license the board
found that Dr Roxy neglected her
patients as she live streamed parts of
their procedures spoken to a camera and
answered viewer questions all about
surgeries were taking place so here we
have a surgeon she's got these women on
the operating table under anesthesia
performing lipo BBL implants all these
surgeries and not only is she on Tick
Tock but she's using these different
medical instruments on these patients
and instead of looking at what she's
doing to them she's more focused with
looking into a camera and talking to a
bunch of people on Tick Tock yes The
Tick Tock audience was more important
than the lives of the women that she had
in her hand fortunately though no one
passed away for my knowledge but you
have some women who said they were
injured by Dr Roxy and experienced
complications
I went in the ER on Friday and
um today is Sunday and I'm still here
um they're gonna be keep me again
definite infection
um I know one is a stab infection and
there's another one I'm not too sure
what it's called but um try to share
this as much as possible so hopefully
more people come forward
because this is this is not okay
she's basically flipped my life upside
down
you also had patients who claim when
they had post-op complications they
would reach out to Dr Roxy only for her
to advise them not to call 9-1-1 not to
seek medical attention luckily those
women had enough common sense they knew
their bodies they knew not to listen to
a more wrong telling them not to get
medical treatment some of them accuse Dr
Roxy of not wanting any other doctors
examining them more so to protect our
brand but not the patience as a result
of all these claims and a few lawsuits
Dr Roxy was suspended back on November
18 2022 by the Ohio State Board and she
made her Tick Tock private the nearly
nine months after that decision the
board decided not to reinstate her
license instead they permanently took
them away from her
yeah yes ladies yes we could just do
anything a man can do and we just do it
equally well you know what's crazy I was
thinking about this when men are con
mans they even con people better than us
like the
octabout that was
on media but women are so addicted to
attention we will live stream us conning
people
that's the funny part honestly I think a
little bit of sexism is okay in the
world I don't understand why sexism is
like this end-all be-all oh like
honestly I would much rather have a male
doctor than a female doctor because men
handle pressure a lot better than women
sorry guys sorry but yes ladies go do
anything a man can do you can do it uh
you do it equally as well you know what
we should be pissed off about all these
men that pandered us and lied us and say
you can do exactly what a man can do and
just as well because they are liars
liars and they are not our friend
um and that's how we get situations like
this because nobody could tell the
pretty blonde lady that she was being an
idiot
and now luckily no one died and they
reviewed revoked her medical license but
that that could have been could have
been bad next on the agenda today is she
crazy or did he make her crazy
this is a phenomenon that I have noticed
that whenever a woman does something
wrong our immediate gut reaction is to
blame the man why in society is it
always the man's fault when a woman does
something wrong for example we had the
popular hit song in the early 2000s by
Carrie Underwood where the lyrics
literally were I dug my key into the
side of his pretty little cooped up
four-wheel drive carved my name into his
leather seats I took a Louis V Slugger
to both headlights I slashed a hole in
all four tires maybe next time he'll
think before he cheats now why is this
crazy one
because everyone was singing along and I
won't even lie Carrie that was a fire
song but but everybody is singing along
to songs that are openly misandristic
why is a woman okay to damage a guy's
property because he cheated this was two
levels of pandering okay one the simply
that men don't have a natural
inclination to cheat and that it might
happen especially if the guy is good
looking and Rich it may happen this is
like the simply that they all do that oh
oh guys don't want to cheat on you they
always want to cheat and I'm not saying
all guys do but this idea that if a guy
cheats on you it is the worst thing ever
you should end your marriages you should
break his property blah blah blah it's
like this simping and pandering to women
instead of admitting men's nature is to
screw everything the same way woman's
nature is to leave you for the better
guy now men accept this about women
they really do they're like you know she
probably will I've heard guys say you
know what of course she's gonna leave
it's not she's not yours it's just your
turn now a lot of women say this is
doomsday whatever but 50 of women do
leave and I don't think they leave
thinking I'm gonna do worse I'm gonna
have a worse man do you really think
like women leave thinking wow I am gonna
have a worse husband no of course we
leave thinking we're gonna do better and
this is the crate the funny thing the
crazy thing
men accept this and they still deal with
us but women want to change the way men
are and Sims will Pander and lie to us
and tell women that men are not the way
they are when the funny thing is the
majority of these simps have never had
the opportunity to cheat now my point
isn't even about the cheating my point
is about the pandering to women that we
do and we see it on talk shows on
daytime TV and the music it's just
pandering and as women we really need to
be sick of this I'm sick of seeing them
post old women and young women's roles
to Pander to us I'm sick of them telling
us we can have everything we can have a
guy that's rich handsome he's not going
to cheat on you I'm sick of them telling
women that nothing is their fault in
relationships ever because it doesn't
help us we'll get to 35 40 years old
never have even having even thought of
what a man wants have you guys thought
about the fact that I got 15 million
views on a tweet talking about how
younger women are more attractive than
older women and all of the older women
were triggered in calling me a doomsday
red pillar do you know how crazy that is
they used to have terms for this an old
maid a leftover woman it doesn't matter
how good you looked if you hit a certain
age you were left over
and you know you could say this was
harsh but at least it was honest
you knew that if you were in a situation
where you were divorced you were shamed
for it but now we are in a situation
where you used to get you used to get
stoned to death if you cheated on your
husband now I'm not saying we go back to
that but my point is this [__] was
honest that's not what we have today
where it's pandering simply and as women
we should actually be pissed off about
all this stuff because all they're doing
is trying to sell to us that is it they
don't care about our best interest what
I care about is objective truth now
here's an example of where the daytime
TV Market was pandering to us women and
simping always question a man who says
oh I have a crazy ex or oh yo she's just
crazy no sweetie my question is what did
you do to make her crazy
there it is it's the same thing when a
woman acts crazy when he is a crazy
ex-girlfriend
it's what did he do to make her crazy
but when a girl has a crazy ex-boyfriend
or a narcissistic ex-boyfriend
it's always oh you poor thing you you
poor baby they just used and abused you
it's the same oh my gosh it is the same
thing with the Tates right now they're
all saying oh the poor girls that did
the cam work you were just used in abuse
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no
one women are way more likely to talk
about a toxic ax than a man I'm sorry
men will downplay how crazy their toxic
exes are they will downplay it much more
much more than the women do where the
women will say oh he did this this this
and this
the men the men the men really move on
they just want peace the women will live
in the past and exaggerate everything so
no no he did not make you crazy you were
either crazy or you're not crazy nobody
can make you anything you know there's
been situations in my life where
I I very well could have Justified
acting crazy but you either have it in
you or you don't have it in you you're
either the type of [__]
to key his car or you're not and I'm
sorry ladies I think if you do that to a
guy you should go to jail because just
because he broke your trust in the
relationship does not mean you get to
key his car it does not mean you get to
go through his phone it does not mean
you get to do all this crazy [__] crazy
[__] is crazy [__] and if you've done
crazy [__] stop blaming it on the men so
now now we have another clip of a woman
acting like a [__] and what do they do
they blame the man
so okay this woman trips and then hits
her husband and this is why I say guys I
swear once you see this you can't unsee
it aged like 38 to roughly 50 year old
women are the worst generation of wives
now I'm not saying my generation is
better but we're not even making it down
the altar you know what I mean but like
the wives of the previous generation
most of them have berated their husbands
so much to the point that they are just
silent for peace they just go with
whatever their wife wants so they can
have peace most of the wives of the
previous generation don't believe they
should obey or submit to their husband
they think that their husbands you know
it's crazy I've heard Christian women
talk about
how their husband's wisdom should come
from them
is that biblical
no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no or their husband has to ask them
for major life decisions no he doesn't
no he doesn't not as the head of your
household but this is what I'm saying
the 30 to 50 year old roughly wives have
been so brainwashed and so programmed
that they don't even know the proper
role of a wife
that's a crazy thing and this is the
level of the wives that are leading this
generation
genuinely what percent of men hit 55
and are happily married
because it's not really up to the wives
to tell us how good of wives you are
it's up to the men
and I think the fact that we have whole
movements of passport Bros
mgtow and honestly the red pill actually
speaks to the quality of the women in
the market I the the older generation
has taught us nothing about how to be a
wife and a mother genuinely because the
majority of them outsourced parenting to
somebody the majority of them left their
husbands or do not submit to their
husbands and the majority of them will
still tell you how great of wives and
mothers they were instead of admitting
that they did something wrong and
helping the next generation of women be
better
but they'll just die on their Hill for
life and do [__] like this where they
blame the guy for everything
and the sad thing is where you have more
single childless women than we've ever
had
we have more homeless women than we've
ever had and I guarantee you're going to
see more
cities legalizing prostitution because
they don't know what to do with all of
these older single women our society is
not built to have a bunch of single
people you're going to see women start
to move in with women you're going to
keep seeing these open cocked
relationships where the woman is running
things and guys I I literally don't
think it is a negative thing to admit
that men are superior to us they simply
are when you look at when you look at
the data women cannot be the best
versions of themselves unless they're
under the authority of a man and it's so
funny because we get this ego in this
narcissism where we think because we
have these cushy sales jobs we have
these these genuinely these jobs that
monetize Beauty so so right now I have a
job talking into a microphone it doesn't
make me better than the average guy who
who's building the buildings 45 percent
of men in society have infrastructure
jobs driving the buses is building the
buildings
truckers Farmers like all of that stuff
so the this idea that women can do
exactly what men can do in society it's
stupid and it's wrong and Men pay the
majority of the taxes they they own the
minority of the debt they run all of the
infrastructure of society it's okay to
admit that men deserve a basic Baseline
level of respect for being men and
giving us the society that we run today
but we have all of these women saying oh
I can only submit
I can only submit at a price like what
is your submission call like it's just
all this [__] nonsense there are
very few wives that actually teach what
it means to be a wife we go through life
literally not knowing I really think
it's up to the older women they should
be teaching us but they're not
um and that's why we get this craziness
in society because again women are
supposed to transplant the culture that
women are supposed to build communities
that that's supposed to be our job to
build communities that transplant
culture or that pass on better word that
pass on culture so when the culture is
deteriorating whose fault is that but I
guarantee I guarantee all of these
people will find a way to blame the men
for picking the women when men have to
adapt to the market we're 99 95 percent
of women are not virgins on their
wedding days and let's be honest the
five percent half are a lot like come on
yet the women will say well but you
picked her you should have picked a
better chick it's just the craziness of
how we will blame men for everything a
woman does wrong in society and I am
just sick of it I'm sick of the
pandering I'm sick of the simply and I
am sick of men and women lying to us you
are not kind by pandering and lying to
women what women actually need is
honesty and Truth
so guys Maybe I'm Wrong maybe I'm just
crazy making this stuff up you know just
just a crazy lady spitting out nothing I
don't know but let me know what you guys
think in the comments like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
drop a super chat if you're in the Live
premiere right now like the video on
your way out and I'll talk to you next
time